the best way to convince your friends  you're a good web developer is to put  fancy animations on your homepage  and the best way to do that is to  reverse engineer other websites like  this animated loading sequence on the  gatsby home page open chrome dev tools  then hit ctrl p  to bring up the animation panel it  automatically records every css  animation on the page  allowing you to visualize and modify the  keyframes now double-click to highlight  an element in the dom if necessary you  can right-click  and force it state if it's a hover  animation now go to the styles tab and  play around with the css code then  animate like a pro by using your mouse  to do a right-click  copy then go into your project and do a  right-click paste